Here are a handful of methods that can
help you during the understand stage.
I'll give you a quick overview
of each of these methods.
The first is 360 degree lightning talks.
As Nadia mentioned, 360 degree
lightning talks are incredibly useful.
The deliverable of the design sprint
should meet the business goals,
satisfy user needs and be possible
with current or emerging technology.
Here are the questions that
should be addressed by anyone who
gives these talks.
For the business side, that person
should be able to address what's
profitable and sustainable for
the business in the long run?
And what are the current business needs?
Anyone speaking to the user
experience should be able to answer,
what do people need?
And what's delightful or
useful to the user?
And finally,
someone should be able to speak
knowledgeably to technical concerns.
What's possible with today's technology?
Or what features can be built now or
over time?
Lightning talks are meant to be a quick
way to address those major concerns.
Now of any of these
activities that you do,
you should be sure to
do user interviews.
You want to talk to users at
the beginning of the design sprint and
at the end of the design sprint,
so you can validate your work.
User interviews allow you to understand
the goals and the motivations of users,
you might also try exploring some of
their emotions and how they feel about
existing products or about particular
features that you want to implement.
If you have existing designs, you can
definitely ask a user about them.
If not, you could always ask a user
about a competitor's design.
The interview should follow
a sort of arc like this.
You want to get to know
the interviewee at first,
so make them feel comfortable and
keep a conversational tone.
You also want to be genuinely
interested in the person, so
you can ask them starter
questions just to build rapport.
Then you can plan your
questions accordingly, so
you can get out their own stories and
the general moments in this diagram.
Be sure to thank the user and
wrap-up with any followup steps.
If you don't have any
current user research,
then you should definitely consider
going to visit actual users.
This would be a field visit.
A field visit or
field study will let you observe how
consumers use similar products or
you can take note of the context in
which users use that product or service.
You can also ask questions about
their behaviors, they're likes and
interests and
their pain points or problems.
You might do usability testing with
them, if you have current designs.
Or you might competitor designs,
if you don't have current ones.
Or finally, you might gather feedback on
early ideas, copy for your webpage or
app and
particular features that users may want.
This would just be concept testing.
A stakeholder map is another necessity
that can help you think about
all the players related to your
business or your industry.
For example, the stakeholder map for
the SuperDuper shopping
app would look like this.
Notice that this map includes internal
stakeholders, such as the user and
external stakeholders,
like the suppliers and specialists.
You could imagine building up particular
features from recommendations of
a nutritionist or allergist.
These specialists might play a role in
recommending foods to particular users
based on their dietary restrictions,
their dietary goals or
their cooking habits.
This last activity is another great way
to get perspective on the industry.
You can check out competitor's apps or
websites to get a sense for
what they're doing.
This can help you figure out what's
happening in your current space or
industry.
And you can also analyze, how's your
approach different from these others?
Is it a subset of features or
is it marketing efforts?
You can also see particular UI
elements or design elements and flows,
that appeal to you and
others that you might want to avoid.
Whatever methods you choose,
you should make sure that you summarize
your findings from the activities.
These findings should be on your mind
and on the minds of anyone on your team,
as you go into the next
stage of the design sprint.